شبح هو الاعتقالات وتهديدات الذي يطال
الشخصيات الفنيه والرياضيه والطبقه
المثقفه من قبل نظام خامنئي لا يزال
متواصلا ومن ابرز هذه الشخصيات البارزه هي
الممثله الايرانيه ترانا على دوستي التي
تتمتع بشهره عالميه لمشاركتها في افلام
نالت جوائز عالميه حيث قامت الاجهزه
الامنيه الايرانيه بايقافها على خلفيه
منشورات داعمه للاحتجاجات للمحتاجين والتي
والمحتاجين والتي تنادد باعدام متظاهرين
وضعتها في منصات التواصل الاجتماعي كما تم
اعتقاله لاعب كره القدم الكردي وري غفوري
في فريق فلاتوس خوزستان بتهمه القيامه
بالسلوك مخزي وتحريض ضد النظام وفقا ما
تداولته وسائل الاعلام ايرانيه
ومن بين الشخصيات المؤثره التي اعتقلها
النظام الايراني كان المغني والملحن شرفين
حاجبور والذي اوذلك بعد ثمانيه 48 ساعه من
طرحه عمل فني
يعبر عن انتفاضه المراه
السلطات الامنيه في ايران اعتقلت ايضا
الممثله والمخرجه سهيله كالستاني والمخرج
المسرح حميد بور ازري بعد ان نشر مقطع
فيديو ظهرت فيه مجموعه من النساء الناشطات
في مجال المسرح دون الحجاب الاجباري
[موسيقى]